[Musique]
la normale pendant la pause on méchaal
est venu me voir en me demandant combien
je lui mets tes potes non sur des
combats vous lui mettez les mains je
peux pas te mettre de bonnes chez j'ai
envie de dire que tu voles maintenant ah
bah alors à moins 10 c'est à mon avis tu
ne sais c'est pas elle a donc là vous le
mettez non j'ai dit que je désirais plus
tard merci michel seydoux nous
rejoignent et sachez que jean michel mr
et sniper aujourd'hui ne laissait pas
facile parce que l'on vit des moments
difficiles
[Applaudissements]
oh
et
m
[Musique]
t
les gars c'est n'importe quoi c'est ça
que j'avais dans cette émission peut
passer d'une danse de ringarde et dans
un instant on va voir périph gauthier
c'est le alors je vous le dis c'est le
taulier des tauliers ça veut dire tous
les avocats l'appel pour qui on le
consulte et c'est la seule télé qu'il a
décidé de faire
touche pas à mon poste c'est pareil vous
a vu ses bars et ses enjeux non non je
vous jure il ya une rigolade tu racontes
tout parce qu'il est venu pendant la pub
et c'est le fire pendant la pub ici
c'est le mac où il était changé de tenue
par ingestion alors j'explique que
pendant la pub les sites la pause
publicitaire pas pardon bonjour bien va
pas bienvenus ça y est 20h11 vous êtes
dompter pmp on est en direct
merci à tous d'être là voilà on cyril a
souhaité passer derrière benjamin
pendant l'injection au le nargue en lui
disant l'air appartient à tout le monde
et en essayant de lui mettre des
pichenettes benjamin voulu commencer à
se battre et regarder la regarde
je ne comprends pas ils vous caresse la
tête en même temps mais gentil il même
voilà et on est vraiment les gamins et
je rappelle la violence le respect du
temps mais ça fait plaisir quand même
c'est pas dégueulasse quand il fait beau
ici on va pas vous montrer des images
qu'on va les laisser vos jolies toiles
et s'il est normal et c'est pourquoi je
sens que tout le monde adore voir fait
expliqué je vais expliquer le contexte
mais jean-luc parce que expliquera bien
le contexte la brochette dans les
quartiers en fait très fort est ce qu'en
fait je vous êtes en train de danser au
moment jeudi à matthieu delormeau viens
danser aussi et la seconde à l'âge où il
fait le beau tout ça et après la le le
délire on l'a ou pas avec le son est
tout aussi vous plairont j pour doter
les spectateurs en aurait évidemment oui
on en a mais remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci
c'est pas possible il va doubler de
volume tesla une fois qu'à une chose qui
double de volume chez vous elle est
19h54 je vais vous montrer ce qui se
passe pendant les pubs aux
téléspectateurs crohn c'est la femme de
benjamin castaldi regarde l'émission
elle se pose des questions
elle a du souci à faire regarder
oh
non non non non ah oui voilà et puis
saint fons et pirro voilà et on n'a pas
la petite chenille
[Applaudissements]
à l'aller chez eux
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]